♪ ♪
>> Jason: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY."
IN OCTOBER U.S. AMBASSADOR TO
THE UNITED NATIONS ANNOUNCED SHE
WOULD BE RESIGNING HER POSITION
AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
YESTERDAY SHE SPOKE WITH SEAN
ABOUT HER TIME AT THE U.N., HER
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND MUCH MORE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW AS
U.S. AMBASSADOR TO THE U.N.
FORMER GOVERNOR NIKKI HALEY IS
WITH US.
GOOD TO SEE YOU,
CONGRATULATIONS.
I LOOK OVER AT THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND WHAT YC?
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN
NORTH KOREA, JERUSALEM IS NOW
THE CAPITAL OF ISRAEL, IT'S NOW
BEEN MOVED TO ITS PROPER HOME.
WE WATCHED ISIS BEING SHUT DOWN,
THE IRANIAN SANCTIONS HAVE BEEN
PUT IN PLACE, AMERICA STRENGTH
ABROAD HAS NEVER BEEN STRONGER
BUT YOU HAVE A FRONT ROW SEAT,
AND MY RIGHT?
>> AMERICA HAS FOUND HER VOICE
BACK, IT'S A GOOD TIME FOR
AMERICA AND THE WORLD.
FOR SOME COUNTRIES THAT'S A GOOD
THING AND FOR SOME COUNTRIES
IT'S A BAD THING.
FOR AMERICANS IT'S A GREAT THING
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
BASICALLY SEEN IS THAT IT'S TIME
FOR US TO START TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE BELIEVED IN AND WHAT WE
DIDN'T.
WHEN I CAME IN, WE HAD JUST HAD
A CUBAN SPONSORED RESOLUTION
THAT BLAMED AMERICA FOR
EVERYTHING.
I CAME IN AFTER THEY DID
ANTI-ISRAEL BIAS AND STANDING UP
FOR OUR FRIENDS AND ISRAEL, WE
AGAIN ABSTAIN ON OUR BOAT.
WE DON'T ABSTAIN, WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE THE UNITED STATES
STANDS AND WE KNOW WHERE WE ARE
GOING.
THERE'S A LOT OF MORAL CLARITY
FOR THE UNITED STATES NOW AND I
THINK COUNTRIES APPRECIATE THAT
WE ARE NOW VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
>> Sean: I WATCHED AN
INTERVIEW AND WE TALKED ABOUT
YOUR RELATIONSHIP TO THE
PRESIDENT.
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE IT WAS A
GOOD COP BAD COP ROUTINE.
YOU WOULD USE WHATEVER THE ISSUE
WAS, YOU WOULD USE HIS STRENGTH,
HE WOULD GO OUT AND BE
COMPETITIVE -- IT SEEMS LIKE THE
WORLD LEADERS BELIEVED HIM WHEN
HE SAID SOMETHING AND YOU WOULD
USE THAT IN YOUR NEGOTIATION.
EXPLAIN HOW THE DYNAMIC WORK.
>> WHAT I SAID WAS THIS IS WHERE
THE PRESIDENT IS, UNLESS WE GET
THIS DONE I CAN'T PROMISE YOU
WHERE HE'S GOING TO GO BECAUSE
HE'S UPSET AND WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD.
THE PRESIDENT AND I HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP.
IT WAS A GREAT PARTNERSHIP, WE
RESPECTED EACH OTHER, I LET HIM
BE HIM.
I TURN AROUND AND USED HIS
UNPREDICTABILITY AS AN ADVANTAGE
BECAUSE IT IS.
FOR MANY TO SAY PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT FROM THE
UNITED STATES, THAT'S NOT A BAD
THING.
I USE THAT AS LEVERAGE AND AS
WAYS OF GETTING US WHAT WE
NEEDED AND HE IS ALWAYS GREAT AT
MAKING SURE HE NEVER LET ANYBODY
GET COMFORTABLE.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT AS A GREAT
WORKING RELATIONSHIP --
>> Sean: MAY BE GOOD COP BAD
COP WAS A BAD PHRASE, MAY BE A
WAY TO SAY IT IS HE LIKES TO
KEEP EVERYONE ON HIS TOES AND HE
KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT HE IS DOING.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HIS STRONG POINT REALLY IS
COMMUNICATING TO LEADERS AROUND
THE WORLD AND I WOULD ALWAYS
TELL THE PRESIDENT AND STRONGLY
BELIEVE YOU GET HIM IN FRONT OF
ANY WORLD LEADER, HE WINS THEM.
HE COMPLETELY WINS THEM.
IF ANY WORLD LEADER THREATENS
THE UNITED STATES HE PUTS THE
FEAR OF GOD INTO THEM.
IT'S THE REASON OUR FOREIGN
POLICY IS SO STRONG, IT'S THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE BEEN SO
EFFECTIVE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY HE STOOD BY IT.
WHEN HE SAID IF THEY USED
CHEMICAL WEAPONS THERE WOULD BE
A PRICE TO PAY AND THEN HE
FOLLOWED THROUGH WITH IT, THAT
SAID A LOT TO THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY THAT YOU CAN'T TAKE
THIS PRESIDENT FOR GRANTED.
>> Sean: NATO DOESN'T BELIEVE
WE MIGHT PULL BACK ON SOME OF
OUR -- WE PAY $0.72 OF EVERY
DOLLAR IN THE PRESIDENT'S
CHALLENGING THEM TO PAY MORE --
IF MEXICO AND CANADA AND CHINA
AND OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES, IF THEY
DON'T BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT IS
REALLY GOING TO BE CONSEQUENCES
TO TRADE DEALS, I THINK THERE'S
A FORCE IN THE WISDOM LIKE THE
ART OF THE DEAL AND I KNOW
EVERYBODY GETS PANIC.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF PANIC
OVER LITTLE ROCKET MAN, MY
BUTTON IS BIGGER THAN YOURS, AND
FIRE AND FURY.
WE NOW HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY OF
HAVING THE ENTIRE KOREAN
PENINSULA NUCLEAR FREE.
>> NOW ALL THE COUNTRIES ARE
PAYING MORE SO WHAT HE DID WORK
TO.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT NORTH KOREA, IT
WAS THAT RHETORIC COMBINED WITH
GENERAL McMASTER CALLING
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES TELLING THEM
TO EXPEL DIPLOMATS, NOT ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE EMBASSIES -- ALL OF
THAT WORKED AND ALLOWED US TO
GET THOSE SANCTIONS DONE AT THE
UNITED NATIONS.
WHILE PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE WHAT HE
WAS SAYING OR HOW HE WAS SAYING
IT, WHAT IT ALLOWED ME TO DO WAS
SAY HE'S BEING HONEST.
HE'S VERY TRUTHFUL, WE NEED TO
PASS THESE SANCTIONS OR I CAN
PROMISE YOU IF THERE IS A THREAT
HE WILL RESPOND.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH YOU
ABOUT THE SAUDI ARABIA SITUATIO
SITUATION.
I FIND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FAR TOO
SIMPLISTIC IN THEIR ANALYSIS,
IT'S FAR MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THAT.
I BELIEVE HE IS RESPONSIBLE, IN
MY HEART I BELIEVE THE EVIDENCE
WILL SHOW EVENTUALLY IF IT HAS
NOT ALREADY, I DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT KIND OF INTELLIGENCE --
THERE ARE ALSO OTHER THINGS.
WE HAVE TO LOOK CONTEXTUALLY
THROUGH HISTORY.
WE HAD TO ALIGN WITH STALIN IN
WORLD WAR II TO DEFEAT HITLER.
I LOOK AT THE EMERGING ALLIANCE
OF UNITED STATES, ISRAEL,
SAUDIS, THE JORDANIANS, AND
MORITZ IRANIAN HEGEMONY AS MAY
BE A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY TO THREAD A NEEDLE.
IT IS FRUSTRATING THEY DID THIS.
I'VE BEEN THE LOUDEST CRITIC OF
SAUDI ARABIA FOR YEARS,
TREATMENT OF WOMEN, PERSECUTION
OF CHRISTIANS AND.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER BUT I
THINK IT'S FAR MORE COMPLICATED
ESPECIALLY BELIEVING THEY DID
THIS.
>> IT'S A VERY COMPLICATED
SITUATION BUT IT CAN BE HANDLED
AND SOLVED.
IF YOU HAVE SAUDI OFFICIALS
GOING INTO A SAUDI CONSULATE, IT
MAKES MBS RESPONSIBLE, THAT'S
JUST WHAT WE KNOW.
OUR UNITED STATES UNITED STATES
PRINCIPLED VALUES WILL NOT ALLOW
US TO GIVE THEM A PASS AND WE
SHOULDN'T.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT MADE A
GOOD FIRST STEP ON HEAT SINK
SHOULD INDIVIDUALS, I THINK WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE HEARTS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SAUDIS
ABOUT HOW THIS DOESN'T FIT THE
MEANS OF INTERNATIONAL NORMS NOT
ACCEPTED BY THE UNITED STATES
AND WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO PARTNER
WITH SOMEONE WHO CONTINUES TO
BRUTALIZE PEOPLE IN THIS WAY.
I THINK WE HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE FOR THEM.
AT THE SAME TIME WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE WHO     YEMEN, WE TALK
ABOUT THE WHO     YEMEN, WE TALA
ABOUT THE WHO     YEMEN, WE TALO
ABOUT THE WHO     YEMEN, WE TALT
IRAN AND THEIR ROLE IN SYRIA, WE
CANNOT LOOK AT SAUDI ARABIA AND
NOT SEE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SUCH
A GOOD PARTNER WITH US ON THAT.
BOTH CAN BE DONE, ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS A FINE LINE WE HAVE TO
WALK, WE JUST HAVE TO DO BOTH,
THEY HAVE TO KNOW WHERE THEY